all right welcome back good day in Las
Vegas counting down all week long to the
Super Bowl and we have Sasha Loftus this
morning joining us now live from
Glendale Arizona Sasha good morning love
having you on the show what are the
players up to over there
good morning Heather well the players
obviously up to a lot today is a big day
for practice but last night was actually
pretty big here in actually downtown
Phoenix they had that opening night
which is just really a big media night
where players coaches everybody gets
asked a lot of questions now people from
all over of course were there as you
would expect they talked a lot about the
big game but they were also talking
about some fun things which is something
they usually do opening nights like this
they were talking about the players
favorite foods and who they're listening
to on their playlists and one AJ Brown
he even got asked to try some spicy
Mexican candy and he did not really like
that idea take a look
okay
[Music]
I probably would have had the same
reaction I'm not a fan of spicy now some
are saying that that was really the last
quote fun opportunity that the teams had
because of course today they start
practice at their respective fields in
Tempe about 30 minutes from here in
Glendale they will have another media
day today separate though they'll have
the chiefs will be in the morning the
Eagles in the afternoon kind of talking
about what their plans are just five
days away now from the big game for now
reporting live Sasha Loftus 8 News Now